[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden dijo que la democracia estaba bajo
ataque y afirmó que los republicanos que
no reconocieron los resultados de las
elecciones de 2020 en las que él venció
a Donald Trump están planeando atacar
los comicios de medio término del
próximo 8 de noviembre
el presidente de Brasil Yair bolsonaro
pidió a los manifestantes desbloquear
las vías pero en un mensaje ambiguo dijo
que apoyan las manifestaciones pacíficas
Y es que miles de sus seguidores
pidieron una intervención de las fuerzas
armadas para evitar el ascenso al poder
de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva tras su
Victoria en las elecciones del domingo
el presidente de Ecuador Guillermo lasso
convocó un consejo de seguridad tras lo
cual ordenó reforzar la seguridad en los
centros penitenciarios de esmeraldas y
de guayas luego de que se registraran
nuevas reyertas tenemos reportes desde
quito
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano se
Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos poco menos de una semana
previa a las elecciones de medio término
en Estados Unidos previstas para el 8 de
noviembre el presidente Joe biden dio un
discurso a sus ciudadanos en donde
condenó el aumento de la violencia
política en el país después de semanas
en donde el mandatario se ha referido a
temas económicos e inflación el
presidente cambió el tono de sus
declaraciones y advirtió sobre la
amenaza que se cierne sobre la
democracia por las mentiras y negaciones
electorales del expresidente Donald
Trump el mandatario fue enfático al
afirmar que el camino del caos en
Estados Unidos no tiene antecedentes es
ilegal y es anti estadounidense a
continuación un fragmento de sus
palabras
los republicanos del maga están poniendo
en duda la legitimidad de elecciones
pasadas pero también las elecciones que
van a acontecer ahora y en el futuro
los extremistas del maga en el partido
republicano que son una minoría en el
partido republicano como lo dije tienen
mucha influencia y están tratando de
tener éxito donde no lo tuvieron en el
suprimiendo el derecho de los votantes y
subvirtiendo el sistema electoral en Sí
también en Estados Unidos el autor de la
masacre en la escuela secundaria de
parkland en 2018 fue formalmente
condenado a cadena perpetua sin
posibilidad de libertad condicional El
veredicto ya se veía venir luego de que
el Jurado recomendara esta sentencia
tras no lograr unanimidad frente a la
pena de muerte solicitada por la
fiscalía por el de 17 personas se espera
que Nicolas Cruz pronto sea trasladado a
una prisión de máxima seguridad
y seguimos con más noticias de Estados
Unidos porque la reserva Federal volvió
a subir los tipos de interés se trata de
un aumento de 75 puntos básicos por
cuarta vez en cinco meses ahora queda en
el rango de entre 3,75% y 4% y no se
descarta Que las próximas subidas para
luchar contra la inflación sean menores
la idea Al subir los tipos es encarecer
los créditos Y hacer que el consumo baje
siguiendo la lógica que a menor demanda
los precios también bajarán el peligro
es que la desaceleración sea tan grande
que provoque una recesión económica
y el presidente de Brasil Yair bolsonaro
envió un mensaje en Twitter en el que
pidió a los manifestantes desbloquear
las vías sin embargo le dio su apoyo a
los manifestantes pacíficos la
declaración resulta ambigua ya que
algunos de sus seguidores se postraron
en la sede de las fuerzas armadas para
pedirle al ejército que intervenga e
impida la llegada al poder de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva el próximo mes de
enero Pese a que obtuvo la mayoría en
las elecciones del pasado domingo
brasileños que están protestando por
todo Brasil sé que están enfadados y
tristes esperaban otra cosa yo también
estoy realmente triste con el resultado
Tenemos que tener cabeza
las protestas y manifestaciones son
bienvenidas y hacen parte del juego
democrático a lo largo de los años las
hemos hecho en Brasil La Explanada
Copacabana paulista tantos lugares pero
lo que tenemos aquí Hoy no está bien el
bloqueo de las carreteras por Brasil
perjudica directamente la vida de las
personas y a nuestra constitución
en Ecuador el presidente Guillermo lasso
convocó a un consejo de seguridad tras
lo cual acordó desplegar más oficiales
en los centros penitenciarios de las
penitenciarías de esmeraldas y de guayas
tras nuevas reyertas y en el marco del
estado de excepción así como un toque de
queda por la escalada de violencia en
las calles nuestro corresponsal en Quito
Gustavo Ortega no se ampliaba
previamente la información
Ecuador vive el cesto o Estado de
excepción declarado por el presidente de
la república a causa de los atentados
ocurridos en las ciudades de Guayaquil y
esmeraldas el presidente Guillermo lasso
reitera que las bandas del narcotráfico
le han declarado la guerra al estado y a
la ciudadanía ecuatoriana por ello
declaró el estado de excepción por 45
días en dos provincias del país y toques
de queda a partir de las 9 de la noche
la policía ecuatoriana pidió apoyo a su
parcolombiano para enviar oficiales para
la lucha contra la criminalidad desde el
31 de octubre hasta la fecha se han
producido al menos 15 atentados con
explosivos ataques hacedes policiales
cinco policías asesinados a sus comandos
y amenazas de motines en centros
carcelarios originados por operativos de
seguridad y traslado de líderes de
bandas criminales hacia otros centros
penitenciarios que han generado amenazas
de líderes desde los centros carcelarios
quienes amenazaron al Estado de iniciar
atentados masivos en lugares públicos
sino regresaban a sus cárceles de origen
en Guayaquil se han creado perímetros de
seguridad
Se cerraron los accesos de
estacionamientos públicos terminales
terrestres y se restringe el tránsito
vehicular y servicios públicos entre
otras medidas anunciadas por la
alcaldesa la clase presenciales fueron
suspendidas en dos ciudades del país
para asegurar a los ciudadanos más de
3000 muertes violentas se han producido
en el país a causa de la criminalidad
hasta la fecha y vuelve a reaparecer El
fantasma de la muerte Cruzada o
intenciones de disolver la asamblea
nacional por parte de algunos
parlamentarios pero el primer mandatario
aseguró que se mantiene en un consejo de
seguridad de estado y se trasladó a sus
funciones de seguridad a la ciudad de
Guayaquil
nos vamos ahora hasta Bolivia en donde
persisten las protestas y los
consecuentes enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes y policías en la región de
Santa Cruz la más extensa y de mayor
potencia económica del país por la
petición de un nuevo censo electoral que
dote a la región de mayor financiación
Estatal este miércoles la defensoría del
pueblo boliviana instó a las partes en
conflicto a que acaben con la violencia
y que se retome cuanto antes el diálogo
previamente hablamos con Sebastián
Crespo postigo economista y director del
comité Pro Santa Cruz en Bolivia que nos
contaba Por qué cree que el gobierno
quiere llevar la actualización del censo
a 2024
es gracioso es gracioso y le digo por
qué Porque justamente todo este año
ministros el mismo director del
Instituto Nacional de estadística
garantizaron que sí va a ser este este
este 18 de noviembre el censo en todo el
país dijeron que tenían ya los créditos
que los dio el banco interamericano de
desarrollo y con plata y estaba todo
listo financieramente y
organizacionalmente pero por un motivo y
que es sencillo son cálculos políticos
decidieron retrasarlo Qué es lo que
ocurre el censo nos va a permitir
justamente limpiar nuestro paro para una
electoral saber cuántos somos dónde
estamos y Qué necesitamos y para ahí nos
va a poder permitir justamente
planificarnos Y estos resultados del
censo que es que el gobierno los quiere
atrasar muchísimo si si esto se atrasan
no van a poder validar la nueva
redistribución de los recursos y también
de los escaños parlamentarios entonces
Esto va a afectar las elecciones
nacionales del 2025
información que no
beneficiaría por supuesto al gobierno
porque donde más se benefician son todos
los departamentos que van a tener
mayores recursos en Bolivia el gobierno
maneja el 80% del presupuesto general
sobre el 20% se reparten en Por así
decirlo en los distintos niveles del
Estado Entonces el gobierno no se va a
ver beneficiado porque realmente van a
salir a luz muchísimas cosas que han
venido ocultando todo este tiempo no el
nuevo propietario y director ejecutivo
de la red social Twitter El Magnate en
los musk anunció hoy que las cuentas
suspendidas aún no serán restablecidas
más que aseguró que se necesita un
proceso claro para hacerlo y que esto
tomará aún algunas semanas con este
anuncio se despeja la duda sobre si la
cuenta del expresidente estadounidense
Donald Trump sería rehabilitada tiempo
para las elecciones de medio término del
próximo martes 8 de noviembre
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a france24 y Recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web
france24.com
[Música]